one of the funny things is that if you
look at the physics journals these days
pretty much every week somebody reports
the creation of a Maxwell's demon how
can that be we still believe in the
second law don't we well what's
happening is these are things which are
doing sensors at the level of individual
molecules and at the level of small
numbers of molecules you can untangle
the second law the second law isn't true
for small numbers of molecules the
second law is a feature of observers
like us who observe these molecules in a
computationally bounded way on a large
scale and so on so the second law is
also a story of the way that we are
observing the universe rather than just
the way the universe is and again the
sort of the key phenomenon is this
interplay between computational
irreducibility underneath and the
computational boundedness of us as
observers of that system